[Music]
watching anime as an adult is
interesting why the amount of character
arcs in a 20-minute
episode I mean really you know M Night
ight wishes he could put this many
twists really into something oh yeah I'm
talking like did this person
die with they came back and they're dead
again but they're back how did they come
back like that that's okay and
then oh this person was bad the whole
time wait they're good or they're it's
just all in one episode it feels that
way yeah okay so I'm uh I'm enjoying it
obviously anime dialogue is
pretty dramatic yeah yeah but you see
why the weeb kids talk like
that why cuz everything is just so like
I can't believe
it do they actually talk like that
though in anime yeah it's very much no
no the the kids that like weep kids yeah
really yeah the a weeb is at any moment
Li liable to I can't believe you'd say
that I wonder why that style like why I
think because it's that oh yeah that's a
good question I think because it's short
pockets of time and sometimes what
you're looking at visually doesn't have
a lot of emotion you have to give it
that emotion ah I see so you know a a a
drawing of a
person
going it's not that powerful no so I
think the vocal you know has to really
convey like right this I am worried
yeah
[Laughter]
oh pardon me madamu I didn't see you
there I just smelled something really
delicious oh wow is that Oni giri that's
my favorite what kind are you
eating
naie mushroom that's my favorite
too you're perfect can I ask you a
favor well I brought
these no I don't want to bite I was
wondering if uh you could put these in
your
hair that's anime okay that's good you
felt the range of emotions there yeah
like why is he so distressed about the
Nar that's another big thing about it
that's my favorite that's another big
thing about anime relax yeah anim anime
is
like the red
shoes I've been dreaming of those shoes
ever since I was a little boy I remember
my mother she would take me by the the
shop and we would look at those bright
red shoes it kind of stresses me out I
would think one day I'm going to be
successful and I too will have those red
shoes it's like I [__] hope he gets
these shoes uh sir he loves you any
questions oh no sorry I'll take the
number one you're a hiring manager for a
company and you have to interview the
guy who thinks his life is an anime I
love the hi I'm looking for Williams
son um Williams I have an interview
today I'm already a little late the
[__] hair you are William son but
you're a girl and you're
so uh let me show you my resume um I
have all my references here uh they're
all my senses let me just
whoa
oh I'm sorry I'm really messing this up
uh just please what was that that was
him falling and looking at her
breast he Bob he'll tell you I'm a good
guy he knows me really well after all he
is my par officer yeah yeah yeah it's
yeah dude anime is like soap opera like
twists you know just in the craziest way
God damn bro it's funny when guys that
watch a ton of anime are like I'm not
very good with women it's like yeah
you're uncomfortable as
[__] you're [__]
[Laughter]
weird you're [__] we stop doing this
ah stop yeah you can just you can just
let there's like there's you know
natural spaces between words Bo that
shirt really uh pops your tits out oops
oh why did I say that I fell
yeah sorry just rehashing his [__] but
that's what it is yeah
yeah there was a look up I always talk
about this I feel I brought this up at
least three times look up Vash the
Stampede there was a dude in my high
school that dressed like this guyy Every
Day He Wore an open red shirt like
Dragon shirt one like that do you
remember that in the early 2000s like
dragon t-shirts like in the same
material as um like a Hawaiian t-shirt
okay look up dragon t-shirt it kind of
looks like guy fiery clothing I think it
was like that almost exactly yeah shit's
sick and um I mean that's just straight
up cool but then he then he had
prescription
yellow tiny lenses like Vash the
Stampede I'm walking into like a I had
to take a shitty engineering
class we had to work in CAD it was hell
but I'm walking past him and just being
the idiot I am this is kind of like a
bold move cuz this dude could have
kicked me with his raver Boot and
[__] killed me okay like he was he
was a tall guy I was not big enough to
be talking slick to him so I just go I
go what's up Vash I've never talk this
guy in my life okay straight to it and
he looks at me and he goes no no he goes
like he does like the Vash thing and I
go no way no [__] way he just did
that yeah and he date and he was dating
a small Asian girl really yeah wow
surprise yeah
surprise who had a twin surprise
surprise yeah so did he talk like that
was he he never spoke oh okay so he was
like a visual anime for me personally
yeah I just always kind of imagined the
voice in his head like all these people
they don't understand me I'm a
gunfighting wizard outside of these
walls if only I could bring my gun to
school then everyone would know how
truly talented I
am Vash you can't shoot up the class oh
I guess I'll kill my parents instead but
it's my
talent
fash why did you bring your gun to
school they keep calling it a gun it's
my Artistry I'll show them oh
no I will show everyone just how
talented I
am mother be gone oh jeez all right
sorry
sorry damn it's a lot more epic when you
do it like I know it's cooler when you
do it like that that's how anime gets
away with some bad
themes